what's up guys
Greg Albee here Andrew here we're gonna
watch a trailer the e3 2018 gameplay
debut or I think it's a brand new game
from PlayStation ghosts of Tsushima
pushy pushy whoa
white man racist we don't know anything
about this game so we're gonna read the
plot description in 1274 the fearsome
Mongol Empire invades the Japanese
island of tissues and slaughters its
legendary samurai defenders Jin Sakai is
one of the last survivors of a noble
samurai clan combat is overwhelming foes
he must pioneer deadly new fighting
techniques the way of the ghost ghost
dog starring Forest Whitaker and wage an
unconventional war for the people of
Japan I just want to know are we gonna
see Tom Cruise and Ken when wet - nah be
in this No maybe I really love it if a
white man's that saved the Japanese
people the grace jokes for this setup to
this brand new stuff Andrew let's check
out what everyone's happen about
PlayStation PlayStation
[Music]
me too mr. Gordon
[Music]
beautiful as expected
[Music]
oh wow
like a patient piece of game player
[Music]
simples this speaks English
where was the Japanese with English
subtitles Mongol invasion day 9
oh he's gonna whoop some ass oh damn I
feel like of it it's like bad ass walk
holding the sword
oh wow
as detailed it's like something out of
like Peter Jackson so you guys old Izzie
three trailers man landscape
see look at that man from the clouds
everything why boo boo come call your
horse good that's your opponent for the
game good
played Red Dead Redemption for a month I
realize you can actually call your horse
Wow
look at that man oh my god that's trippy
man it's not over the flowers whoa
[Music]
mesmerizing
as really mesmerizing
I just wanna be in this world right now
we're all thing I don't even care who I
just want to see him kill some people
right now who dares rotted
[Music]
one minute oh snap
keep out the throw down like the music
you too mr. Alba let me give you a hand
okay
shut you gotta get someone hot with
boner
you're late you're impatient where's the
monk
the bastards beat me to him now they're
torturing him at the temple come on
horse
where's Nobu need him
like here this fall yeah likes over you
like how you get deeper his horse he
gets more beautiful but dark rich just
like I went down a brutal way man he's
got hops
he's got hops people there's a little
like Assassin's Creed cool that's got
realistic hops
I love for Batman ninja to just show up
do it do it just throw your sword man
all right that's just like Batman Arkham
Knight what are your own fear multi take
down in Batman Arkham Knight that's so
similar oh yes
that's cool how Jeff's like a quick
cinematic shot that was dope
when I said it similar other than the
killing part but similar he'd take down
that was sick though yeah the cinematic
graphics and the gameplay blend really
like incredibly well with each other
[Music]
oh no he's worked his ass off to save
him
stand aside Gian you betrayed my family
so she just wanted to kill him herself
onto the story we fight
Mongols win now Wow one as red leaves
whoo
I really love that this actually has a
samurai toe
never liked them like a cinematic
samurai town you know
[Music]
it's got a western tone as well as
samurai samurai films and western films
weren't exactly for you mean spaghetti
westerns
[Music]
man damn look at that look at the leaves
so distractingly good chop her head off
murderer damn this is chapter 9 they're
ruining a big clock
[Music]
yeah they're coming that's our enemy
[ __ ] that's cool firing arrows that's
cool as you're doing a play to avoid
arrows is one together
[Music]
you should do it
which is kind of being annoying right
now
that's beautiful
let me get you weak so we can battle the
sucker punch zack snyder's sucker punch
this is why that was a cool ending
though in terms of you you're under the
impression that he's just gonna kill her
at first you know when the gameplay is
going on I thought that was really
touching moment really quick what I love
about that is you're doing gameplay at
that time while you're doing gameplay
this story is really advancing still
because the arrows would fire them are
still shooting at them so you're like I
gotta get out of here but instead of
doing this part of the game that's
always a really intense part to me with
like the real bad guys are closing in
right now so you think he's probably
just gonna kill her I like that he
doesn't kill her it's a visual
storytelling moment because the whole
time he's like those are enemies coming
you think he's gonna kill and say just
hand to the store and she's get
something ready to fight with him I
don't have any comments about them
speaking in English we fight my selfish
side would want them to speak in
Japanese language and having those
subtitles I don't know everyone's gonna
want that though for what we got I think
the voice acting is great I think it
would be really cool if they gave you an
option like for you know people want to
see it in the the Japanese version like
you know you can have the English
dialogue if you want you can also have
it in you know Japanese where you got
English sub tells that'd be cool if they
could do that just kind of echoing off
what you said I love like you know the
bone arrows coming at them when they
were actually fighting and again it
advances the plot but it adds tension
and weight to the situation just yeah
when you feel the real bad guys are
coming and you don't want to see them
fighting even we're not totally yet
investing as we don't know the full
details the story gives very good visual
storytelling just from the atmosphere we
got on this from the flowers to the
leaves file already invested in the
atmosphere at least you know and I just
I want to be in this world what I've
seen from the plot looks very
interesting already but it's this
atmosphere like I just don't want to be
in and I want to you know write on Nobu
and then go through the forest have the
flowers I'm through my face like that
looked awesome
III 2018 is full of trailers that will
impress the hell out of you with their
visual landscape but that shot when he's
on top of the mountain there were so
many details there that I just could not
get over from the fog the sunlight
coming in through the clouds and craters
are illuminated over some parts of the
trees the burning buildings way in the
background and then all the flowers and
everything
it's just all in that one shop where
he's looking at the top of the mountain
I thought was being immensely beautiful
I think the fighting style is cool too
how they do fight like samurais even in
the first person he kills we just saw
the Spider Man trailer where it's a lot
of crazy combos the whole time and here
it's not like that it's very tactical
precision and when he's gonna strike and
what strikes is gonna be doing you're
saying he doesn't have super strength
like Spider Man I'm saying he doesn't
have super spider is the only point I
was trying to make this entire video I
like a lot of the stuff I like how
violent it is it felt like something
like Quinton Tarantino you know yeah
violent level but there was definitely
one move we were talking about where it
takes like out three guys at once if you
play the Batman Arkham games the most
recent one Batman Arkham Knight they
installed something that's called fear
take down where you can take down about
up to five guys once you upgrade it and
they did a similar thing here the
difference is obviously Batman doesn't
kill in that game this guy's just
slicing them yeah but again the
similarities not saying that's a bad
thing I just I like how they're you know
paying homage saying we like what you
did we're gonna you know infuse that
into our thing it's just the tone alone
feels like a samurai film feels like a
martial arts yeah you know you said like
it kind of feels like a Western and you
know the Magnificent Seven is originally
inspired by Seven Samurai right that's
correct
yeah which inspired Star Wars which
inspired another magnificent set I like
that it's more than just cool visuals in
the world the actual tone throughout
while you're doing gameplay and while
you're doing cinematic Clips it feels
like a samurai movie that'll um makes it
that much more exciting for me for me
for me for me even it's like long
opening shot with the wind blowing and
the trees like this is staying on the
wind in the trees for a long time before
even enters frame and it's such a
beautiful master shot kind of have to
pay attention to go oh there's a guy
right there yeah so one other thing I
wanted to add that I did love the music
like I just don't really getting me into
it actually like works with the combat
and with acetone though they're setting
like the music just perfectly blends
with everything that's going on well
this feels like one hell of a warrior's
journey right here I'm excited to check
this game out I definitely want to at
least pick it up for a couple nights and
see how I really feel about it cuz this
looks like a really good time alright
guys well thanks for watching are you
guys excited to check this game out let
us know what's your favorite sci-fi
movie
you guys can subscribe to the reject
name launch of them whoa whoa
click notification bells the subscribe
buttons don't really work although event
horizon is a top contender it's the
director of Mortal Kombat come on man
can't forget that you could check out
Andrew on the movie source channel
fantastic YouTube channel oh you know in
Cloverfield paradox was well that was a
real a disappointment
and also I check us on patreon
full-length TV show reactions weekly q
and A's oh man music video coverage
would love to have you become a patron
eject today star trek into darkness best
villain they've ever had